Pete: Hey, it's Pete.
I'm in Jackson Hole today and I'm hanging
out with a good friend of mine, Mike Zusman.
And, Mike is the founder of Carve Systems-
a security consultancy.
Mike is a pretty well known security researcher
in his own right.
So, we actually rode some powder today- hit
the mountain, and decided why not squeeze
in a g33ktalk.
[To Mike] Thanks for sitting down and chatting.
Mike: No, happy to be here.
Thanks.
Pete: We have an interesting topic lined up.
Mike's going to refresh himself a little bit
as we're talking and actually we even have
a little fire place action.
So, make it a little cozier in here.
Mike: For the true mountain vibe.
Pete: Yea, totally.
Why not do something different right?
So, we want to talk today about mobile application
security, and what you can do to secure your
mobile apps.
If you're a developer, how should you be thinking
about security in terms of mobile devices
and mobile applications?
What are some best practices?
What are some architectural issues?
What are the main things that you should be
worried about and concerned about as you're
building and architecting your application?
So, Mike, your background is as a programmer,
as a sometime/one-time hacker, as a-
Mike: Sure.
Pete: -security consultant...
Just fill us in and tell us how you got interested
in mobile security in the first place.
Mike: So, a long, long time ago, I was an
application developer myself.
I was programming on the Microsoft web technology.
So, classic ASP, COM, Visual C++ back in the
day, around- up until about 2004 when a made,
kind of a little shift in my career and I
went to work for a SSLVPN application firewall
vendor.
And, that's where I started to focus a little
bit more on breaking applications, and having
been someone who had written both secure and
insecure applications, I took to it pretty
easily.
Coming out of working for this app firewall
vendor, I went into more of a pure corporate
AppSec role and lasted there a little bit
before I just went full-on into AppSec consulting,
and being a breaker and someone who helps
fix security vulnerabilities.
Pete: And, you've spoken at conferences as
well, right?
Mike: Yea, I've been at BlackHat and DefCon
and CanSecWest...
Pete: What's the most basic thing that a software
engineer should realize when they're approaching
mobile application security?
How is mobile app security fundamentally different
than regular web app security, for instance?
Mike: So, when you're creating a web application,
we kind of have a little bit of a walled garden
mentality.
We can put comments in our code and can do
sloppy things because we don't have time to
do them properly.
And, they sit on our web server, and as long
as that web server doesn't get hacked, or
compromised, our dirty secrets are somewhat
safe.
But, when you're writing a mobile application,
it's similar to writing off the shelf software
that's going to be in a retail box, or that
you're going to get on a DVD.
The software's going to be in someone's hands.
They're going to have the ability to reverse
engineer it and figure out how you wrote it,
and see that- OK, maybe you've architected
and implemented it properly, or maybe you
made some mistakes with regard to security
and privacy.
Pete: And, not to mention that they have control
of the physical device as well, right?
Mike: Right.
Pete: Which, physical security is sometimes
an overlooked aspect of computer security
in general, but most computer security professionals
know that if you get access to the physical
device, in most scenarios, it's pretty much
game over.
Mike: Sure.
We have that same problem with laptops.
But, with laptops, we have additional controls.
We have full disk crypto and things like that
and we have access control, we have domain
policies, and there's a lot of hardening that
can be done to a corporate device or even
a personal device.
A personal laptop that if you happen to lose
it, your risk is somewhat controlled.
But, with these mobile devices, they're not
as mature.
We don't have a lot of the controls or the
ability to harden or lock down these devices
as we do with a laptop.
So, if writing an application that deals with
potentially sensitive data like credit card
data or even just email, how you store that
data on the device becomes very important.
If that device is lost, or stolen, or even
jail broken now- Now that we're developing
on these sandbox environments on a mobile
devices, there's sometimes an err of, 'well,
the OS is going to handle this stuff, so we
don't need to handle it as developers.'
But, once a user jailbreaks their device,
a lot of that security is removed.
So, now your application is in a far more
hostile environment than you original thought
it or expected it to be.